ce
salut à tous
aujourd'hui c'est un studio trois
spéciales que je vous propose studio 3
spécial rock français avec en grande
majorité des tournages fait par notre
équipe nous verrons pierre chérèze les
dogs jean patrick capdevielle sapho jean
falissard les sacks pustules mama béa et
bernard lavilliers alors à juste titre
vous vous demandez probablement pourquoi
dans ce studio 3 spécial rock français
je ne vous annonce pas trust téléphone
ou starshooter qui sont quand même les
trois plus célèbres groupes français
mais ya une raison très simple c'est que
trust et téléphone on les retrouvera la
semaine prochaine et starshooter était
enlevée avec nous en direct
il y a quinze jours cela